what's going on everyone welcome welcome
welcome into another exciting edition of
Market takes and if you know what if you
enjoy economic growth if you enjoy
consumer spending well you know what
today is a beautiful day it's a great
day for you we are talking about today's
third quarter GDP report US gross
domestic product it's an exciting day um
a big report better than expected
actually and the expectations were
pretty high um so we're going to break
down all of that for you today right
here on Market takes we're going to talk
about of course what the headline
numbers were in the report and how they
compared to expectations we're going to
take a look at the market reaction we
have seen some a pretty significant
reaction markets and it's not maybe what
you might expect so we're going to get
into all that in just a minute we're
going to talk about how this GDP number
we got today fits in with some of the
other data we've seen for the third
quarter and how that could affect things
moving forward and we're going to talk
about what this this GDP report tells us
about the future because you know here
on Market takes we are always looking
forward even though it is backward
looking data last thing of course we're
going to talk about what to watch for
next couple big things coming out next
week do you want to be here for and
we'll be right here on Market takes so
we'll talk you through that so first
things first what the GDP report showed
let's throw a chart up here on your
screen right now uh show you what GDP
was this is a reading and this is what
we've seen over the past 10 years I want
to throw the past 10 years up there so
you can see where we are compared to the
trend now we point out that those 2020
numbers we've cut this off at 20% so if
you remember back in 2020 we had a
decline in GDP that was about 30% and
then we had an increase in GDP that was
over 30% so we're not seeing those
because we're cutting this off at 20 to
give you a better idea of the scale but
if you look at this latest report what
you see on your screen to the far right
is that third quarter number just
jumping up and spiking and really
reversing the trend the trend had been
for the last few quarters remember these
are quarters so these are 3mon periods
you had seen those numbers moving
negative and remember if you if you
remember in 2022 we got those
back-to-back negative quarters you're
seeing those there but then GDP got
positive compared to those negative
quarters and then we were moving lower
it looked like we were moving towards 0%
you remember the FED even predicted GDP
would be right around 0% for 2023 well
this quarter reversed all that and just
kind of sent things in reverse and see
it was the highest reading that we've
had on this GDP number since the fourth
quarter of 2021 you see that big jump
there if you remember 2021 economic
growth was just booming you were seeing
those High numbers if you compare that
to the numbers pre-2020 as in Pre
pandemic you see those numbers there are
right around that 2% this is what they
call the trend growth number and
economic growth was right around there
right around two maybe a little higher
maybe a little lower but we saw in 2021
economic growth really just pick up you
saw that Trend kind of reverse then it
looked like in 2023 we were going to
start getting lower and lower and lower
and then this Justus defies that Trend
so really this report right here and
this chart illustrating the way that GDP
has moved and the way that this third
quarter number really defied the trend
that we had seen coming into this report
for about the past year you had seen
those numbers moving lower so GDP was
expected to be 4.7% so we were slightly
better than expected a little stronger a
little closer to that 5% number and hey
you can round up pretty easily 4.9 to 5%
uh it is worth noting that consumer
spending Rose at an annual rate of 4%
that's really what's driving this GDP
number is consumer spending consumer
spending increased in the second quarter
at
0.8% so 0.8 to 4% that's an increase of
fivefold that is a huge increase from
one quarter to the next and that's
really what's driving this it really is
all of us going out spending our money a
lot of that we know if you've been
watching Market takes a lot of that's
been been credit card spending a lot of
that's been debt spending or debt fueled
and finance spending a lot of folks are
still borrowing even though those
interest rates are high if you have a
credit card you're paying the highest
rate ever to carry a balance so keep in
mind that's what's driving a lot of this
growth let's talk really quickly about
current dollar GDP AKA nominal GDP cuz
those numbers even more impressive
88.5% 8 and half% on the nominal number
that's huge at an annual rate the
economy grew $ 56.5 billion in the third
quarter to a level of
27.6 trillion that means our economy is
growing at a rate around you could round
it up to 28 trillion that is big in the
second quarter GDP only increased 3.8%
so again more than double the increase
in the previous quarter uh
$249.58
that surprised to the upside 35% so G
pce inflation the fed's favored metric
for inflation the thing that the Federal
Reserve looks to when they're making
their decisions about what they're going
to do that was higher than expected 3
and a. half% versus 2.7 so a big beat
and inflation Rising much faster than
expected in the third quarter um and it
was only
2.4% previously uh this is this is a big
big increase on the GDP or on the pce
front excuse me when it comes to
inflation and
1.7% in the previous quarter so you're
seeing an acceleration of inflation that
we have talked about here on Market
takes those other media sources that
you're watching they haven't talked much
about the rise in inflation because
they've been focused on core inflation
because the fed's been talking about
core inflation but here in Market takes
we're independent thinkers right we look
at what the data says not what we want
it to say and really what the data has
been showing is a consistent pickup in
overall inflation inflation is worth
looking at from the core perspective
which strips out food and energy if you
just want to talk about oh well here's
what we think the real pace of inflation
is that's the feds talked about but when
it comes to what we're all paying what
consumers are actually paying what's
happening with actual prices that's
headline G or that's headline PC
headline inflation and that has been
moving consistently to the upside
surprise to the upside in this report
that's big so the core pce figures those
actually came in below expectations 2.4%
on core versus 2.5% expected in 3.7% in
the quarter so a big decrease when it
comes to core inflation but an increase
when it comes to overall inflation what
does that tell you well it tells you
that food and energy prices are rising
significantly and doing a lot of work
keeping prices elevated the big takea
away from that is what does core mean
versus headline really what it means is
if Energy prices and food prices
continue to rise that's going to
continue to elevate overall inflation
and keep inflation high so it won't
really matter what happens with core if
those food and energy prices stay high
the FED likes to look at core because
those prices can be volatile they can
jump one month fall the next but they
have consistently been staying High food
prices especially have held high and
held at higher levels Energy prices were
starting to compare to a lower period of
energy prices from a year before and so
that's why you're seeing some of that
come down but still Energy prices are
accelerating consistently month over
month so you're going to want to watch
that the fed's going to want to watch
that and that's going to tell us a lot
about what's going to happen next with
the economy speaking of what happens
next with the economy let's talk about
what's going on in the markets and let's
take a look right now I want to throw up
on your screen what we're seeing on
wsj.com in terms of what's happening in
the market really we have seen an
acceleration downward in terms of the
market you see there the S&P 500 we're
moving down down down stocks opened a
little bit negative but they have just
moved consistently negative and the
NASDAQ has been even worse you see that
consistent lower Trend and the Dow which
had popped positive has now moved
consistently and solidly negative
negative we've seen a couple other
reports but really the pop on this
report the takeaway was okay this is
higher than expected growing fast than
expected let's take let's talk about
bonds if you watch Market takes you know
it's all about bonds and we are seeing a
consistent move down a solid move down
across the board in terms of bond yields
going down you know when bond yields
fall that means prices rise so what are
folks doing they're buying bonds buying
safety buying that government debt and
we're seeing a solid consistent move
lower especially on the longer end here
right around this 10year note you see
the 10year the seven-year but the
biggest move is right here in what they
call the belly the three five and seven
years these moves moving in terms of not
really what the fed's going to do
although you do see a 7 you see a seven
basis point move in the 2-year yield so
that's more tied to what they think the
fed's going to do what investors believe
the Federal Reserve will do than really
these expectations for overall growth
that's moving lower as well folks
thinking okay maybe we overshot maybe we
thought that you know bond yields have
risen too high so let's go ahead and buy
some government debt let's buy some of
that Ultra safe asset and you see those
yield moving lower currencies you got
ECB president Christine lagard talking
right now you're seeing the Euro move
lower on some of her comments I think
that's really what's what explains that
one thing I do want to talk about really
briefly is this move in cryptocurrency
we are seeing Bitcoin down just a little
bit but look at that price Bitcoin lasts
over 34,000 that is a big move up
ethereum up over 1,800 crypto has moved
up in a big way you check this year to
date number boom look at what's happened
just over the past week in terms of
Bitcoin you're seeing a similar
phenomenon in terms of ether uh that's a
big move in the crypto market last but
not least talk a little bit of a little
bit of Commodities you're seeing oil
prices fall we're seeing oil prices well
below that $90 level that's a big move
in terms of oil coming down staying
below and holding below $90 also we saw
gold pop above $2,000 per ounce earlier
today gold has moved back away from that
since then so early this morning you saw
gold above $2,000 for the first time in
a while we've moved away from that and
really this Market reaction just
illustrating the Market's thinking in
terms of growth in terms of inflation
and in terms of those recession odds
that we had been talking about really a
recession for 2023 is basically out the
window right now it'd be really
difficult for the National Bureau of
economic research to come in and declare
a recession for 2023 so it's all about
2024 and what what looking for there
let's talk a little bit about the
details within the report I think the
most interesting thing about the report
was just a wide range of growth remember
consumer spending drove this but it's
all about where consumers were spending
and consumers were spending everywhere
there were expectations that the big
increase would be oil and gas prices but
that's not what we're seeing in the data
we are seeing a wide range of consumer
spending coming from everywhere want to
read you something real quick from the
report the increase in Real GDP quote
reflected increases in consumer spending
private inventory investment export
state and local government spending
federal government spending and
residential fixed investment that were
partly partly offset by a decrease in
non-residential fixed investment blah
blah blah Imports which are a
subtraction in the calculation of GDP
also increased so we imported more folks
were just buying buying buying and
really as a country we were exporting
more as well one thing I want to talk
about is disposable personal income that
increased by about 1.9% so 2% in the
third quarter compared to an increase of
6.1% in the second quarter so disposable
personal income is in what folks can
spend on whatever they like after their
bills are paid after the credit cards PA
after all the things that they have to
pay for have been have been purchased
and the money has been spent what's that
disposable income how much they have and
we've talked right here on Market takes
about how real wages have been coming
down we've talked about how inflation
adjusted wages when I say real I mean
when adjusted for inflation those have
been coming down consistently by the
federal federal reserves by One Federal
Reserve measure infl uh real real real
wages excuse me inflation adjusted wages
have been coming down for six straight
months so personal income or personal
disposable income real disposable income
um real sorry disposable personal income
down 1.9% in the third quarter real
disposable personal income down by 1% so
negative so we saw an increase of 2%
compared to an increase of 6% uh in the
second quarter and then when it comes to
real dispos income as in inflation
adjusted that was down 1% so we've seen
wages falling when adjusted for
inflation we're now seeing disposable
personal income declining when it come
when you compare it with the rate of
inflation personal savings the personal
savings rate was 3.8% in the third
quarter compared to 5.2% in the second
quarter people are saving less they're
spending more they have less money to
spend their wages adjusted for inflation
are lower these are all things to watch
out for when it comes to what comes next
for the economy how this GDP fits with
other data we saw in the third quarter
well let's talk really quickly about
retail sales let's throw a chart up here
on your screen so you can see just what
we're talking about what you see there
is a consistent clear Trend right growth
and retail sales growth moving lower
falling from those high levels of 2022
as we get into 2023 and then what do you
see in the third quarter July August
September those three reports showing
retail sales increase that just
illustrating again reinforcing this
theme that we had seen the third quarter
was an anomaly was a reversal of the
trend we see the same thing when we look
at the jobs report let's throw the jobs
report chart up there on your screen so
you can check that out what do you see
there boom on the right side of your
screen July August September we've now
got all those reports in showing a
reacceleration and a reversal of the
long-term Trend and again this just
illustrating what we saw from this GDP
report and that's really and that's in a
number of different pieces of data the
third quarter everything picked up
consumers went out and spent spent spent
and there are worries that that
obviously isn't going to hold I want to
read you a quick quote from my girl
Quincy Crosby Chief Global strategist
for LPL Financial quote she says the
fed's job isn't done and it does not
appear that higher interest rates are
doing the job for them keep that in mind
my man Greg Doo ey paron Chief Economist
says quote while these signs while these
signs of economic grow of economic
strength excuse me will fuel
speculations that the economy is
reaccelerating
we do not expect such strong momentum
will be sustained so keep that in mind
again keep in mind the overall trend of
consumers spending a lot more than they
have using credit to buy things that
really is what we see going on in the
economy and what we see for this third
quarter and why economists are saying we
don't think this is going to last we
don't think this big reversal of the
trend that we had seen is going to
continue into the fourth quarter and
into 2024 so what does this report tell
us us well let's talk about what it
tells the Federal Reserve it says that
growth remains strong and it's time to
lock in and watch food and energy prices
because if those stay elevated it
doesn't matter what core inflation does
all that matters is what happens with
overall inflation what's actually
happening with prices the FED is going
to want to watch food and energy what
does report tell investors says that
consumers were strong July through
September but the holiday season will be
very important if consumers are tapped
out if they spend all their money in Q3
and there's not more for Q4 there's a a
lot of businesses here in the US economy
that are very dependent on holiday
shopping to survive so if they've tapped
out and they're not going to be able to
spend in Q4 that's something to
definitely watch out for investors are
going to want to watch out for that what
does this tell everyday people says that
prices could start to rise again we know
that when companies see people willing
to spend and willingly spending they
raise prices and that can create a cycle
of inflation where inflation starts to
pick back up again also if oil prices
stay high that could push prices up as
well because we know that the oil price
is factor in everything anything you get
is delivered by some vehicle that runs
on oil the fed's going to want to watch
that as well last but not least what
comes next well we get the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index that's
tomorrow on Friday you're going to want
to watch that that has been coming down
consumers are not feeling good I think
it has a lot to do with those inflation
adjusted wages and inflation adjusted
disposable income numbers that we talked
about in this GDP report we want to
watch that on Monday we'll be right here
on Market takes doing a look ahead to
all the big numbers that we are going to
get the following week next week is a
big week we get not just the jobs report
that's the big one but we will get the
employment cost index we'll get the
jolts report we get the Challenger job
Cuts report we are going to get the
housing cost index there is a ton of
data out next week that is going to move
the markets we'll tell you all about it
right here Market takes Monday morning
at 10: a.m. and for more be sure to
check out my podcast wsj's take on the
week don't miss it Sunday morning 6:00
a.m. it drops be there be uh as a square
don't do it we cut through the noise to
explain the major business and financial
news that may move markets all so you
can make smarter investing decisions
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
I am Dion Rolan reporter for the Wall
Street Journal that's going to do it for
us here on Market takes we hope you'll
be with us Monday morning 10:00 a.m.
eastern we'll see you there next
time